[Musique]
bienvenue dans le duel des éditos votre
émission de débat qui analyse chaque
semaine l'actualité politique au
sommaire l'écologie alors que se tient
actuellement la côte 26 et les craintes
liées au réchauffement climatique tient
une place de plus en plus importante
dans la campagne présidentielle au point
que tous les candidats se revendique
soucieux de l'environnement et qu'ils
proposent chacun leur solution pour
défendre la planète et développer le
secteur énergétique lui aussi au coeur
des attentions avec l'augmentation des
prix de l'énergie alors que proposent
les candidats faut-il miser sur le
nucléaire sur l'éolien la croissance
verte ou la décroissance c'est le débat
de la semaine alexis poulin et jacques
de guillebon vous livrent ensuite leur
vision sur un dossier qui pourrait être
au coeur de l'actualité politique du
monde d'après mais d'abord faut-il en
finir avec les sondages à chaque
présidentielle le nombre de sondages
augmente drastiquement au point qu entre
1965 et 2017 il aurait été multiplié par
40 le quotidien ouest france vient
d'ailleurs de renoncer en publié alors
les sondages sont ils les outils la
démocratie ou fausse-t-il les scrutins
faut-il continuer de miser dessus malgré
les critiques liées à leur manque de
fiabilité
c'est l'acte eu des éditos commençons
d'abord par une première question
essieux selon vous les sondages ont-ils
réellement le pouvoir de faire ou de
défaire un candidat
bonjour jacques je réussis les sondages
faire ou défaire un candidat non je
crois pas les sondages sont là pour
donner une certaine idée de l'opinion
mais surtout pour créer la fabrique de
l'opinion et on le voit de plus en plus
avec cette frénésie sondagière qui va de
pair d'ailleurs je crois avec le
gouvernement des influenceurs
aujourd'hui comme n'ya plus vraiment de
politique tout ce sont des communicants
ils ont besoin de sondages pour se
positionner est pour bat policiers leur
image oui oui je suis d'accord avec vous
et j'ajouterai que c'est pas anodin que
les sondages soient une invention
américaine à l'origine dans les années
20 et 30 d'une sorte de vision de la
démocratie spectaculaire c'est à dire
qu'il faut faire croire tout le temps
qui est en train de se passer quelque
chose à l'électeur quoi qu'ils sachent
même pas ce qui est encore dans le
projet dans le programme de ces des
candidats pour qui il va voter mais il
faut qu'ils dansent surtout en france où
on adore cette cette élection
présidentielle qui comme une coupe du
monde qui arrive tous les cinq ans il
faut absolument qu'il se passe quelque
chose et qu'on est con décision préfère
telle personne ou telle personne et
qu'on se voit là qu'on se doit dans ces
sondages je crois qu'ils aussi il faut
expliquer un peu pourquoi il ya un
mensonge autour des sondages un déjà le
terme institut c'est un terme trompeur
on a affaire à des entreprises de
marketing et pas de marketing politique
la plupart des sondages 80% des sondages
qui sont faits en france sont faits sur
des produits des slogans attestent de
slogans d'une grande entreprise des
panels de consommateurs en réalité est
très peu de sondage sont politiques même
si les politiques en sont friands on le
voit aujourd'hui nicolas sarkozy et
devant les juges pour les sondages de
l'elysée parce qu'il demandait à patrick
buisson à l'époque de faire beaucoup
beaucoup de sondages sur tout et
n'importe quoi pour se positionner ça
n'a fait qu'empirer le gouvernement
desnel macron a explosé également les
chiffres en termes de financement le
gouvernement dépense et 2,6 millions
d'euros en 2021 ses 2,1 millions ça
c'était en 2020 journée on voit bien que
c'est pas fini et dans le budget
communication général de l'elysée à
doubler en 2020 et jusqu'à 28 millions
et aujourd'hui on a une rallonge pour
2021 de 30 millions d'euros pour le
budget communication donc je crois que
ce gouvernement des influenceurs va de
pair avec ce gouvernement des sondages
qui trompent les français et je crois
que plus personne n'est dupe parce que
c'est du sondage low cost il ya une
enquête du monde qui vient de paraître
comment j'allais ballard alesi qui
montre comment ces panels sont tout à
fait
un jour un journaliste du monde du
bonheur qui s'est fait passer pour un
pour une personne il est devancé par
elta pour au moins 10 personnes à dire
en prenant des âges des sexes et
ddt
vers des professions différentes et qui
a répondu à pas moins de 200 sondages
sur sur quinze jours ou trois semaines
et qui explique que ce que sont ces
sondages qu'ils en appellent des
sondages omnibus c'est à dire vous allez
souvent vous allez 350 question
totalement différente est ce que vous
allez faire vos courses ici est-ce que
vous avez une voiture et au milieu est
ce que vous pensez qu'à trop d'immigrés
en france où est-ce que vous pensez que
ça n auriez raconté un sondage voilà qui
est fait à l'évidence pour le savoir
s'il est ce que les gens répondent aux
compositions de du pas encore candidat
eric zemmour et mais sans que eric
zemmour soit cité danser sur comme
candidat c'est simplement vécu des
questions des phrases que lui-même posé
on demande aux français ce qu'ils en
pensent et s'est noyé au milieu de deux
questions sur voilà le pouvoir d'achat
des français ou des choses qui n'ont
aucun rapport mais c'est bien le
problème parce que on a affaire à des
sortes dubé risation enfin des sondages
low cost qui n'ont plus rien de
scientifique or le sondage quand il
commençait en 65 le premier sondage
politique il a encore cette aura en dix
ans peut-être qu'on peut en faire
quelque chose de réel mais quand on
regarde les chiffres c'est une fois sur
8 les sondages à six mois des
présidentielles sont justes donc c'est
vraiment n'importe quoi en réalité et à
3 mois ou un mois des présidentielles on
est à une fois sur trois donc on reste
quand même avec des énormes surprises
jean-marie le pen en 2002 au second tour
les sondages ne sont pas là pour au
final mais dernière qu'elle avait les
dernières départementale aussi
normalement talent les sondeurs se sont
parfaitement planté notamment sur la
part régionale sion et sur ce que ça
allait donner et cela étant dit
j'aimerais apporter une petite
contradiction je me demande pourquoi
aujourd'hui d'un seul coup tout le monde
se met à taper sur les sondages et sur
les sondeurs depuis deux mois notamment
à gauche sinon parce que ces sondages
donnent une vision de la société
française qui portent l'extrême droite
on va dire marine le pen plus eric
zemmour plus quelques autres petits
candidats à 35 % dans les sondages et la
gauche elles stagnent en dessous de 2
30% donc il ya aussi un petit jeu qui
est peut-être un peu malsain de la
gauche de taper sur les sondeurs
aujourd'hui en disant regardez ça ne
représente pas du tout ce qui est la
société française et c'est d'ailleurs
comme ça que terminer le joris du monde
de luc bronner son article en disant on
cherche à nous donner une société une
vision de société très droitiser mais
peut-être que ce n'est pas le cas et on
aura la grande surprise de voir au mois
d'avril qui en fait tout le monde est à
gauche comme d'habitude je crois que
c'est ce pas seulement la gauche quand
l'un grands quotidiens comme mon ex
france décide d'arrêter de publier des
sondages d'en parler ou même d'en
commander savoir que tu as de la droite
non plus non mais c'est quand même bon
on peut pas dire non plus qu'il soit
extrêmement à gauche c'est ouest france
donc il ya une réalité aussi je pense
dans la fatigue sont d'agir de dire on
ne peut pas continuer de faire la
politique de cette façon là c'est
dangereux c'est exactement comme
l'algorithme sur les plateformes ou sur
netflix à la fin on va avoir finalement
des personnels politiques qui sont tous
les mêmes on va lisser en fait avec des
panels de consommateurs dans et
finalement vous voulez quoi mener civ
plutôt comme ça est plutôt comme ça
c'est pas des produits et je crois que
c'est cette porosité entre le monde du
marketing le monde de la politique doit
cesser et le sondage on est typiquement
le l'archétype et et on arrive à un
débat politique qui désintéresse tous
les français et c'est ça le problème et
je crois que ça sert à rien de continuer
de faire des sondages si c'est pour
sonder des pertes des personnages qui
sont tous les mêmes qui sont tous les
mêmes et qui font sondés toutes leurs
propositions on l'a vu récemment pour
parler d'eux lire eric zemmour qui dit
qui s'élèvent contre le permis à points
qui devrait priver 4 le lendemain il ya
un sondage qui montre que les français
sont plutôt pour le permis à points
c'est à dire qu'ils vont tester comme ça
des propositions voir ce que ça donne et
les perpétuer ou d abandonner si jamais
le sondage n'est en rien contraire c'est
pas le sondage qui fait qu on abandonne
la peine de mort en france c'est pas le
sondage qu'on mêle ivg c'est pas le
sondage qui fait qu' on fait des choix
politiques avec les représentants
politiques or on voit bien qu'il ya une
désertion du politique à la fois le
parlement qui ne sert plus à rien dans
un régime ultra présidentielle comme la
vème république et puis le fait de dire
les politiques ont peur de leur ombre
c'est à dire si jamais je serais trop
courageux ou trop disruptif alors je
vais sans doute perdre beaucoup trop
d'électeurs ou me positionner là où je
ne voudrais pas être pour tirgu les
récupérer un siège et c'est là où eric
zemmour ben c'est le chien dans un jeu
de quilles parce que lui il s'en fiche
il n'a pas encore de siège il n'a jamais
été élu il peut dire ce qu'il veut alors
là tous les autres politiques se
regardent et disent qu'est ce qu'on va
faire vous lirez ans on est d'accord
mais là eric zemmour je dois montrent
que peut-être on peut essayer de me
d'avoir une proposition politique en
dehors des sondages c'est à dire qu'il
est arrivé justement comme le chien dans
un jeu de quilles et de manière
disruptive en dix ans qui pensait enfin
en tout cas on en croire qu'ils disent
qu'ils pensent mais sans doute est-ce le
cas et sans se soucier du tout du qu'en
dira-t-on et de ce que disent les
sondages peut-être fait que des journaux
comme en france ne veulent plus publier
de son avis à la fin donne raison à eric
zemmour malgré le fait qu'ils avaient
pas de sondages avant
place au débat de la semaine avec la
récente augmentation des prix de
l'énergie la coop 26 qui se tient
actuellement à glasgow et l'urgence à
atteindre les objectifs de
décarbonisation fixé par l'accord de
paris l'écologie s'est imposé comme un
sujet central dans la campagne de la
présidentielle
chaque candidat ayant ses propositions
entre la volte face des manuels mâcon
sur le nucléaire une droite focaliser
sur une écologie souverainiste et une
gauche divisée sur le sujet quelles
propositions des candidats apparaissent
crédibles de poids doit être fait
l'avenir énergétique de la france au
vont se débat avec une première question
messieurs après son discours à la coop
26 et son plan d'investissement en
france 2030 emmanuel macron tire-t-il la
corde sur le sujet
[Musique]
non emmanuel macron n'y a pas du tout la
corde sur le sujet il a menti ou s'est
trompée depuis le début de son
quinquennat sur l'écologie il est arrivé
en 2016 2017 en disant que dans son
logiciel progressiste il fallait
forcément faire entrer l'écologie parce
que c'était censé être le progrès ça
plaisait aux français il est parti sur
des choses comme on va supprimer le
glyphosate d'ici la fin du quinquennat
il a changé un an après il avait on s'en
souvient on a peut-être oublié mais
c'était nicolas hulot qui était son
ministre de l'écologie qui est parti
avec pertes et fracas et en claquant la
porte
emmanuel macron a fait négocier le c'est
à face à ceux traités avec un niveau
identique voilà qui est totalement anti
écologique il a continué à faire
exploiter des hydrocarbures enfin bref
il a aujourd'hui il nous dit à nous
tenir un discours à la cop16 en se
vantant de ce qu'est la france ce qui
n'est pas tout à fait fausse et mais ce
n'est pas lui ce n'est pas dû à lui que
la france aimez beaucoup moins de de co2
que ses partenaires ou ailier équivalent
en occident mais grâce au nucléaire en
grande partie et il vient faire la leçon
alors que pour l'instant il n'a rien
changé de fond dans l'écologie non il a
fait exactement ce qu'il fait depuis le
début de la communication il s'est
positionné en champion du greenwashing
et pas de l'écologie il a repeint en
vert rappelez vous son premier grand pas
dans l'écologie c'était ce one planet ce
mythe où il se met en scène avec des
stars mondiales et où il sort cette
petite
vidéo sur le mec planète great games
high co new dreams and confused
oui oui c'est xeed
because we are fully comme et est
because we leave
wever oui oh oui oh cheikh jassem ben
responsibility
mec en planète great game
maker macron green again non mais voilà
avec cet angle est formidable mais quand
fenêtre great games est resté quand même
il a été même qualifié de champion de la
terre un rappelez-vous et on voit que
son bilan en matière d'écologie et bien
c'est du greenwashing n'y a rien
derrière exactement comme la convention
climat d'ailleurs il réunit ses citoyens
pour dire finalement c'est très
important l'écologie donc on va discuter
et le seul truc qui sort alors qu'il y
avait beaucoup de propositions qui
sortent de cette assemblée citoyenne
c'était d'inscrire le climat dans la
constitution rejetée par le sénat
puisque ça n'a aucun sens finalement
d'inscrire le climat dans une
constitution mais c'était encore un coup
de greenwashing qui la même tombe à
l'eau exactement et on était censé avoir
un référendum aussi sur le sur
l'environnement qui n'a qui n'a jamais
eu lieu qui est aussi tombé à l'eau ou
jamais de même la france n'a jamais
respecté les accords de paris de
réduction de ses émissions mais ça tout
le monde s'en fiche on est emmanuel
grondin rappelons-nous après cela
consultation de ce panel la deux le
citoyen sur le sur le climat avait dit
dans un média dans un média en ligne qui
n'allait pas forcément parce que 150
personnes s'étaient décidés là-dessus
appliquer tout ce qui est demandé qu'on
n'allait pas revenir à la bougie et
vivre heureux comme des amis quelque
chose comme ça ce qui montre en fait
vraiment quelle encre et 17,6 me tient
la question de l'environnement et les
questions écologiques mais en side est
raccord avec avec la droite classique et
sont les allèrent même peut-être une
partie du ps c'est à dire qu' on cherche
à nous vendre des changements des
transformations écologiques
environnementales à partir du moment où
ça relance la croissance et où on va
créer des emplois et en impression c'est
ça la seule chose à la fin qui vaille
c'est ça c'est d'essayer d'avoir de la
croissance aux environs de la croissance
verte comme ça on a à la fois les
intérêts et la bonne conscience oui
alors ça n'empêche pas évidemment il ya
beaucoup de d'emploi qui peuvent être
créés dans les filières
verte comme on dit le sol et les
renouvelables etc il ya la finance aussi
qu'ils s'intéressent la finance verte
lors elle a ses limites mais elle essaye
là aussi d'éviter de financer les
énergies fossiles même si aujourd'hui le
champion du cac 40 qui reste totale ça
reste les grands énergéticiens et on
voit bien que les coptes se succèdent et
continuent d'être des mises en scène un
peu morbide de l'incapacité des
dirigeants mondiaux à changer quoi que
ce soit la dernière cops est en ce
moment à glasgow ils sont 400 à venir
enfin pour 400 jet privé à venir oui
pour 120 chefs d'état avec les multi
senti milliardaires comme jeff bezos ses
13000 tonnes de co2 rien pour sa great
attenberg n'était pas là donc on a
trouvé une jeune kenyane pour la
remplacer pour dire voilà je vous ouvrez
vos coeurs soyez sympa a fait quelque
chose pour la planète c'est vraiment un
cirque assez triste et alors on a on a
ils ont décidé quelques quelque chose à
la marge sur la déforestation les
objectifs de 2030 ne seront pas tenues
on le sait les grandes forêts qu'étaient
les poumons de la planète rouge est
maintenant du co2 donc on est encore sur
un point de bascule et on s'attaque non
plus aussi au 2 mai au méthane on a vu
que maintenant les émissions de méthane
était aussi un gaz qui réchauffer le
climat et la ccc pratique puisque le
métal on attaque trois pays en
l'occurrence la chine l'inde et la
russie qui eux ne sont pas signataires
bien sûr de l'accord contre les fuites
de méthane puisque c'est des fuites
globalement donc on voit bien que même
là sur les gaz à effet de serre sur la
la reforestation
malgré l' alerte des climatologues des
scientifiques les dirigeants mondiaux
sont là pour faire du profit continuer à
ce que la machine tourne même si elle
nous envoie dans un mur climatique
programmes est exactement et emmanuel
macron est vraiment coupable d'
hypocrisie là dessus si vous avez vu
récemment ce document qui est sorti
selon lequel pour essayer d'imposer la
filière nucléaire française au devant
l'europe mais les maquereaux négocierez
secrètement avec les pays de l'est comme
la pologne ou la tchéquie qui eux-mêmes
consomme du gaz en grande quantité pour
faire rentrer aussi le gaz comme une
énergie verte noire offre devant ces
réunions européennes donc si je te vends
mon nucléaire comprend ton gaz et qui
vont être contents et on fait croire en
même temps qu'on est en train de
diminuer les les émissions savoir ce
qu'est scandaleux et domaine j'aimerais
qu'on regarde cette petite vidéo
d'emmanuelle coint la coop 26 qui est
venue faire la leçon
tout le monde et on parlera ensuite de
ce qu'il a fait réellement trop d'entre
nous prennent ici des engagements et
ensuite signent des accords commerciaux
qui font exactement le contraire nous
notons nous pouvons plus continuer à
avoir une planète qu'on fait fonctionner
selon une grammaire et des règles qui
n'intègre pas en son coeur en son coeur
ses contraintes nos accords commerciaux
doivent refléter nos engagements
climatiques
il a tout à fait raison c'est un grand
acteur sauf si c'est exactement
l'inversé exactement aplomb qu'il ya à
peine un mois la france a été a été
condamné pour n'avoir pas respecté
justement ces engagements climatiques et
parce que donc les émissions de co2 ont
continué à augmenter mais voilà emmanuel
macron nous dit qu'il faut respecter nos
accords donc qui commence par le faire
lui-même déjà pour la france avant
d'aller faire la leçon à d'autres pays
mais sans compter que si on parle bien
sûr du renouvelable ou l'allemagne a
réussi à voir davantage d'énergies
renouvelables elles l'utilisent aussi
massivement le charbon tout comme la
pologne tout comme la chine qui a
relancé beaucoup des usines à charbon
parce qu on est en crise le pétrole
coûte de plus en plus cher il se fait
rare alors on utilise du charbon
personne n'a la solution à la question
du climat est l'ailier a pratiquement à
celle de l'énergie et aujourd'hui on a
des filières évidemment en france on
peut dire qu'on peut être fier de ce
qu'on a fait avec le nucléaire même si
évidemment on n'a pas des solutions
miracles pour les déchets
l'enfouissement on les envoie à
l'étranger également cessé vraiment pas
une énergie propre comment on peut dire
mais c'est une énergie qui ne produit
pas de gaz à effet de serre ces énergies
qui aussi est menacée par le
réchauffement climatique puisqu'elle
dépend de l'eau pour le refroidissement
des centrales donc derrière il n'y a pas
vraiment de réflexion alors on a vu sur
le plan france relance 2030 sur
l'énergie c'est les minicentrales alors
se faire des centrales plus petit et
pouvoir en mettre davantage sur le
territoire le père est un fiasco on a vu
le prix qu'il coûte c'est d un chantier
faramineux qu'on n'en voit pas la fin et
finalement on se dit que c'est une et ce
n'est même pas une énergie nouvelle
génération alors que les chinois eux
avance sur le thorium sur d'autres
aspects de l'énergie nucléaire nous on a
l'impression qu'on s'est embourbé dans
le p r pendant des années c'est sûr et
il ya le nouveau fantasme qui est
l'hydrogène aujourd'hui soit il mais
qu'on nous vend c'est là comme hier on
nous vendait les éoliennes avant de
s'apercevoir que c'était une vaste
arnaque que des gens se sont gavés sur
les éoliennes et je dirais que des
politiques qui ont cédé notamment madame
pécresse dont on peut se demander quand
il était ministre du budget en 2011 2012
et qu'elle a fait voter il ventait ce
que le crédit pour le pour l'éolien
pendant que monsieur pécresse son mari
était arrêté d'alstom et ça pose un
petit problème déontologique aujourd'hui
on nous vend l'hydrogène comme étant la
solution demain où les panneaux solaires
sans qu'ils aient de réelles réflexion
sans qui en plus de filière pour les
panneaux solaires en france on sait pas
les fabriquer non plus comme les
éoliennes et on s'apercevra dans dix ans
que c'était encore une fois peut être un
fantasme un rêve une nombre et pour
laquelle on a lâché la proie qui pour
l'instant restent sans faire de
propagande le nucléaire en france qui
serait ce la seule chose qu'on est tous
sous la main pour l'instant on n en a
une vraie filière avec des vrais
compétence est reconnue à
l'international
là sur l'éolien sur l'électrique
également remplacer le parc automobile
par l'électrique encore une fois d'où
viennent les batteries comme on recycle
des batteries comment on produit
l'électricité pour financer autant enfin
fourni autant d'électricité alors qu'on
va être toujours consommateurs d'énergie
il n'y a pas de réflexion vraiment
l'éolien également le solaire pas pareil
ce n'est pas nous qui produisons la
dépendance elle et elle est là elle est
réelle et la question bien sûr de la
soif d'énergie finalement est-ce qu'on
peut produire autant en consommant moins
est-ce qu'on peut réduire la facture
énergétique c'est ce qu'on essaie de
faire avec l'isolation des bâtiments il
ya eu quelques chantiers qui ont été
faits mais rien comparé à l'ampleur de
la tâche et puis la question c'est
surtout l'industrie aujourd'hui ce qui
pollue massivement c'est le secteur
industriel transport l'agriculture
également parce que tout la modernité
finalement toute la l1
l'économie des trente glorieuses repose
sur le pétrole or si on doit sortir du
pétrole ça veut dire qu'on doit revoir
toute l'organisation de cette économie
est aujourd'hui je vois pas l'ombre
d'une réflexion sur la réorganisation de
la production économique la production
industrielle sans le pétrole non et
parce que la vraie question il a que
delphine batho qui l'a posée aussi je
pense que la question de la décroissance
c'est à dire est ce qu'on fait une
décroissance choisie dans certains dans
certains secteurs notamment sur la
consommation énergétique des bâtiments
tout ça on se dit qu'on va rénover mais
en fait personne ne se demande s'il faut
pas baisser un peu la consommation dans
l'agriculture c'est la même chose la
manière dont le produit aujourd'hui un
kilo de boeuf en dépensant 50 litres de
pétrole points et bien ça c'est
scandaleux et pour l'instant personne
nous pose cette question c'est à dire
que l on a tapé sur eminem accroît son
gouvernement mais les républicains ne
sont plus que pitoyable sur le sujet de
l'écologie ils ont aucune proposition
quasiment sauf vous dire oui on va pas
finir à la bougie on peut retenir comme
des amish on va essayer de faire une
écologie humaniste et cros est
croissante et qui va créer des emplois
les verts sont une caricature de l'autre
côté je pense pas quand on vous dit
qu'il faut arrêter les sapins de noël et
qu'il faut enlever de l'esprit des
enfants le raid aérien lancé c'est
scandaleux d'une autre façon et pour
l'instant on a assez peu de propositions
qui soient à la fois valable réaliste
mais réaliste ça veut pas dire
uniquement oui il faut continuer à
consommer on va passer ainsi que réalise
ça veut dire aussi il ya ce mur
écologique qui a devant bien sûr que la
notation de la température qui va
arriver très très vite il y est déjà une
cassure politique entre ceux qui nient
le changement climatique ou qui unit
qu'il soit le fait de l'activité humaine
et ceux qui l'ont actée et disent qu'il
faut faire quelque chose déjà là on a
deux camps qui s'opposent après dans
chaque camp il ya effectivement des
façons de voir notamment sur le lait
l'énergie sur aussi quel est le sujet
prioritaire est ce que ces lots est ce
que c'est la production économique
est-ce que c'est l'énergie là encore on
a des sous groupes mai mai clairement la
question centrale c'est que y'a pas un
candidat qui est plus qu'il n'a plus de
discours
écologique enfin tout le monde est
obligé de passer par la case écologie la
question c'est qu'est l'écologie
évidemment et je crois que la
décroissance c'est un terme mal employé
par la question c'est quelle croissance
c'est pas une décroissance et on peut
toujours être dans un monde de
croissance mais quelle croissance et
pourquoi alors oui davantage de bien
qu'on arrête les famines programme et
qu'on fasse enfin que les maisons soient
construites et ne consomme pas trop
d'énergie que les gens puissent avoir
une vie qui ne consomment pas parce que
le problème aussi c'est d'inégalité dans
ce monde incertain consomment peu en une
vie ce que personne ne consommera en
formulant donc il ya un vrai problème
d'inégalité et tout ça je crois que ça
pourrait être un sujet central de
l'élection mais on en est loin
[Musique]
direction le monde d'après alexis poulin
et jacques de guillebon vous éclaire sur
l'actualité politique de demain avec un
sujet qu'ils ont choisi d'évoquer et
c'est vous alexis qui commençait de quel
sujet avez vous choisi de parler cette
semaine
[Musique]
alors pour le monde d'après j'ai choisi
de parler d'alexis colère je sais pas si
vous le connaissez c'est le secrétaire
général de l'elysée le bras droit des
modèles macron il était au ministère des
finances également alors lui il a déjà
eu des affaires de conflits d'intérêts
auparavant avec le groupe el c'est un
groupe de transport et msc croisières de
croisiéristes il était aussi à la
présidence du port du havre conflit
d'intérêts parce qu'il était cousin très
proche d'un des grands actionnaires du
groupe msc et qu'il aurait pantoufler
avant de revenir à l'elysée aurait
utilisé son réseau bien sûr dans
l'administration pour favoriser le
transporteur et l'on apprend deuxième
affaire colère qu'il aurait également eu
un rôle dans le rachat de suez par
véolia les deux grandes l'eau les géants
de l'eau français c'était l'an dernier
les actionnaires les syndicats s'étaient
mobilisés parce que il y avait aucune
raison que veolia mange suez si ce n'est
de détruire davantage d'emplois et de
faire qu'on n'aura pas forcément un
champion français même si veolia bon je
suis est d'augmenter démarche peut-être
augmenter les marges bien sûr et avoir
de nouveaux marchés publics et comme la
régie de l'eau de paris et d'autres or
on apprend que le parquet national
financier ouvre une enquête et ça
pourrait être la faire de trop peut-être
pour alexis colère alors qu'on rentre en
campagne présidentielle est ce qu'ils
monnayent mac on peut le garder à
l'elysée il était également
dans le halo de la cellule riposte lors
de la sphère benalla on le voit c'est un
peu le factotum des modèles macron il
est là pour tout faire mais quand il ya
trop d'affaires eh bien peut-être que
jupiter va devoir se séparer de son
faire valoir mais est ce qu'on sait ce
qu'il a gagné dans cette affaire pour
l'instant toujours pas d'accord non sais
pas pourquoi il serait intervenu alors
que son intérêt à lui lui et l'état
parce que j'encadrais quand l'avez dit
que sans doute cette fusion se passerait
bien il y avait également jean-pierre
clamadieu l'ancien patron d' angie qui
étaient intervenus donc on voit qu'il y
avait quand même une attention toute
particulière de la part de l'elysée sur
ce deal d'accord rappelons tout de même
que alexis colère est présumé innocent
et c'est seulement une enquête
préliminaire qui est ouverte sur lui moi
je vous parlais quelque chose qui n'a
absolument rien à voir enfin quelle
autre à l'autre extrémité de l'échiquier
mais dont on parle assez souvent qui est
monsieur eric zemmour voilà donc est ce
que eric zemmour on va déclarer sa
candidature bientôt tous les
journalistes se pose cette question là
tous les français tremble etc at on se
demande s'il va être candidat non pas du
tout heureusement pas si vous êtes
candidat c'est que la ville a encore en
revanche ce qu'on ne sait pas et que je
pense rond qu'on peut essayer
d'expliquer c'est que sa candidature il
va pas la déclarer maintenant tout le
monde le pouce avec art et maintenant
parce que voudrait que ce soit éclaircie
tout ne parle du 9 novembre qui serait
le jour de la mort du général de gaulle
à colombey les deux églises c'est a
priori dans les équipes zemmour ils
savent pas encore exactement comment ça
se passait mais ils se disent que c'est
le plus tard possible qu'il faut qu'il
annonce sa candidature parce qu emmanuel
macron lui-même ne l'annoncera sans
doute pas avant février et que je pense
qu'il ya un an mais à côté chez les ch
et les zemmouris sts d'imaginer que leur
candidat est à peu près l'équivalent des
manuels macro et qu'il faut qu'il se
calme aussi bas peu sur lui que ce
modèle en ce début de campagne de
zemmour c'est un décalque de ce qu'a
fait mme bouille ronde en 2016 2017
c'est la différence que c'est un des
quelques subi c'est-à-dire qu'ils ont
été lancés en pré campagne malgré eux ce
par des sorties dans la presse qui les
ont forcés à se découvrir alors que eric
zemmour imaginer après la sortie de son
livre faire un tour de france ça corps
pour aller vers les dédicaces mais sans
qu'on que bruissent partout le fait
qu'ils seraient candidats et donc pour
l'instant ils subissent plutôt la chose
et ils ont intérêt d'après eux à
repousser le plus loin possible cette
annonce de candidature parce que de
toute façon dans la tête des français il
est déjà candidat et que cette seule
candidature n'aura pas d'effets
stupéfiant géant qu il va l'annoncer
mais en revanche ça va le placer comme
candidat c'est-à-dire devoir se plier à
toutes les règles de base de la
démocratie de telles qu'elles sont pour
l'élection présidentielle et pour
l'instant il préfère continuer sa
carrière de servir dans les comptes de
campagne enfin tout ce qu'il fait
aujourd'hui déjà comptabilisés comment
ça se passe parce qu'il a un qg de
campagne ce tour de france c'est déjà
une campagne on le voit qu'il remplit
des salles et derrière puis va se
déclarer tard plus il tord les règles
c'est un oui dont les candidats qui eux
se sont déjà déclarés déclaré sa
candidature aujourd'hui ça voudrait
répondre à des questions comme quel est
votre entourage quel est votre équipe de
campagne sur quel et quelle partie vous
avez créé qui vous allez présenter aux
législatives qui vous suit et je pense
que pour l'instant ils sont pas encore
arrivés à construire ça totalement donc
il a aucun intérêt à se déclarer et là
il peut jouer encore le trublion qui de
toute façon est accueilli par des foules
immenses partout où il va en france des
gens qui ont ri di cu bien profiter de
son livre mais devant qu'il fait des
meetings politiques une drôle de
campagne avec des drôles de candidats
bon ben oui tout cas on en parlera la
prochaine fois également or va en voir
l'excitation
c'est la fin du duel des éditos vous
pouvez retrouver cette émission en
replay sur notre site rt france point tv
et en podcast sur toutes les plateformes
vous pouvez également réagir dans les
commentaires et sur les réseaux sociaux
via le hashtag ldd eux à la semaine
prochaine pour un nouveau duel des
élites
[Musique]